moment of the sexual experience would
ask the young lady who's your daddy
this should be remixed if officer
akeemov is watching
this could be the next remix masterpiece
dude because just wait till you see what
happens here oh officer officer akimov
is here
uh that's beautiful
who's your dad i'm joined today by
pastor james david manning
oh i'm a christian
[Music]
is the most successful pimp on planet
earth to reverence the word of god to
trust it to preach it to teach it
loads and loads of money and
tons and tons of life loads and
loads of money and tons and tons of lies
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
[Music]
george bush and george bush jr have been
penetrated
by at least 100 men in their anus a
hundred thousand two hundred thousand
strong i didn't do it that's not my
problem
oh i got down on my knees
i didn't do it but i was tempted sounds
like quite an
[Music]
and evening of money and tons and tons
of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
and loads of money and tons and tons of
lives
loads and loads of money
and tons and tons of lives
let me say something to you about
marketing
starbucks has done the exact same thing
that coca-cola has done
except they've done it we've seen them
that certainly
seems to be a story that has been missed
[Music]
how do you know that it flavors the
coffee gays tend to love
each other's semen
how do you know that it flavors the
coffee gays
tend to love each other's semen
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money
and tons and tons of lives
[Music]
and no of money and tons and tons of
live
loads and loads of money
and tons and tons of life
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way
extra points if you can sample trump
saying massive dumps and me talking
about it
in a song please do it
big massive dumps big massive dumps
[Music]
[Music]
that it was massive
[Music]
dump big massive dumpsters
[Music]
toilets 10 15 times as opposed to once
dumps dumps dumps
[Music]
dump big massive dumpsters dumps dumps
jump jump jumps
what is going on here what is going what
is going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive
dumpster
good deal okay
what is going on here what is going what
is going on
sam who it's just beyond parody
oh no sam cedar the election
what is going on here what
dumps
all right welcome everybody uh those
were the comedic and
musical stylings of office akimov not
officer akima of office akimov always
taking submissions for new material
uh people who have sent some in that
you've not seen yet there is only one
explanation they just
weren't good enough okay so um
we have so many things to talk about now
i'm being told
that sam cedar is going to be
debating or i guess talking to
stephen kenneth destiny benell ii
oh no sam cedar is that is that
happening right now or maybe we would
just look at that a little bit
um because i am a little bit curious
about it
uh let's see people saying it's going on
right now let's take a look at that
um oh it's for mature audiences um you
know when we talk about
uh forgiving student debt and uh
you know again this is also you know
money that the the government has lent
and
it's it's not even man i talked about
this with stephen not that long ago
i i just don't see the the the either or
uh option here i mean
i if if wealth you don't perceive
wealth as having an i always get the
impression stephen is like
busy doing something else during every
one of these conversations
i i can understand on some level why i
perceive it that way but
in terms of like real living
life um to have
i mean look sam when i was 20 or 23
i was making uh you know 9 000
a year and i was eating uh you know
exclusively chinese food because i work
in a chinese restaurant
but to be honest i wasn't terribly
worried about my uh
future in the way that you know maybe
someone else working there uh
all right so we're gonna check back in
on that because there is absolutely
major major breaking news let me tell
you guys a little story
okay this is a story in which if
republicans wanted to do
an investigation of what happened on
january 6th
they had the opportunity to do it in a
truly bipartisan way
where what had been stipulated initially
was
you would have um democrats picking five
members
and republicans picking five members and
it would be bipartisan
subpoenas could only be sent out if both
the demo the the democratic chair and
the republican vice chair
agreed that a subpoena was going to be
sent out et cetera et cetera et cetera
and republicans said no we're not going
to do it
and so now there is going to be a probe
because democrats have pushed forward
with it republicans given the
opportunity to select
some people decided to put insiders
of the insurrection not direct but
indirect insiders by perpetuating oh we
can't trust the election all this stuff
including jim shorts jordan and now
nancy pelosi is saying
some of these people should be witnesses
they can't be part of the investigation
and all hell has completely broken loose
let's take a look at this pelosi bars
trump allies
from january 6th probe republicans
vow boycott house speaker nancy pelosi
on wednesday rejected two republicans
tapped by house leader kevin mccarthy to
sit on a committee investigating the
january 6th insurrection
a decision that republicans denounced as
an egregious abuse of power
mccarthy said the gop won't participate
if democrats won't accept these people
pelosi cited the integrity of the probe
in refusing to accept the appointments
of indiana congressman jim banks
or ohio congressman jim jordan i did a
story today about this and i said
all five of these are edge cases
but banks and jordan they perpetuated
the big lie that led to the insurrection
this is sort of like putting you know um
[Music]
can people give me some analogies this
is like putting
the um fox to guard the hen house
this is like putting o.j simpson in
charge of what happened to nicole brown
simpson
this is like putting guys please please
this is like putting the cookie monster
in charge of
investigating what happened to the
chocolate chips
this is like dear god
this is like putting me in charge of
what constitutes an
immorally low membership discount
it's like putting rudy giuliani in
charge
of what constitutes legitimate hair dye
i don't know okay um so anyway nancy
pelosi
is completely right to do this and by
the way
by the way um
nancy pelosi selected republican liz
cheney to be on the committee and liz
cheney thinks
it's fine not to have banks and jordan
on this committee i'm going to get to
those clips
momentarily uh it is incredible what is
going on
it was written on the wall that this was
going to happen let's in fact
look at some of those clips right now uh
we'll see where are we going first
okay here's kevin mccarthy saying
if nancy won't allow us to have who we
want
we'll run our own investigation you know
what
you don't need to do that kevin there's
no point in doing to have the
insurrectionists investigate the
insurrection we don't even need it
we will run our own investigation right
we have law enforcement we have military
he almost sounds trumpy in here we have
doctors we have people from all walks of
life we have doctors
they want to know the answer the
american people deserve that they don't
deserve
politics guys the insurrectionists are
going to tell us the truth about what
happened that day
what's wrong with that nothing to worry
about
they don't deserve destroying the
institution no committee
in congress will work they've looked
into it super strongly
and they've determined they and donald
trump were not at fault
if one person is picking all who can
serve
this has not happened not one person
right i mean nancy pelosi vetoed two of
their picks because they're completely
absurd
um here's the cast of characters that
came forward to talk about this
i don't even recognize most of these
people i know this is kevin mccarthy i
know this is jim jordan
but i don't even know is one of these
guys banks i'm not sure
um here is so
so a reporter actually asked a good
question which is
you know what you oppose the opportunity
you had for an investigation
mr leader you're complaining that you
don't have a bipartisan
opportunity here to investigate january
6th but you stood in the way
of a bipartisan commission that was
about to be made up of independent
members
right no i didn't
your conference voted against that uh at
least a majority folks we've looked into
the riots
it turns out antrifa was at fault
voted against that and it was blocked in
the senate why did you not allow
that to go forward if what you say you
want
is a bipartisan investigation into what
happened on january 6th
for the same politics pelosi played then
at the same time when she used the scope
of that
remember how he didn't have you know the
old setup
pelosi wouldn't have had veto power you
could have had jim jordan on there you
could add banks on there long it took
on january 13th rodney davis and myself
both requested a 911 commission
even those who ran the 911 commission
criticized nancy pelosi for what she
wanted to do
we had officer evans killed on remember
who ran that commission
friday but she said you couldn't look at
that
if you study the 911 commission they
didn't study what happened on just
september 11th they study what built up
to it
but she said no you could not do that
yeah so this this is so dishonest so
do do people want me to explain that
because every every single one of these
lines
is a lie and it's so insane like should
i just explain
that lie
okay people want people want the
explanation okay good
so i was gonna do it anyway but i was
gonna pretend people wanted so this is
the only explanation i'll do
kevin mccarthy is saying we wanted
a contextual investigation we wanted an
inve and i see the super chats everybody
relax
he's claiming we wanted an investigation
that would look at what led up to the
january 6th riots but understand that by
that
they meant uh antifa blm protests
from 2020 because they want to say
the violence they say took place then
somehow explains what happened on
january 6th
they want to include an investigation of
the
shooting of steve scalise like three
years ago
that's the context they want to include
and they wanted to include an
investigation of whether
the rioters were justified
in believing the election was stolen
that's the context they wanted
which nancy pelosi said no that is no
that has nothing to do with the
investigation the real context would be
how mccarthy and jordan and trump and
all these different people
were ginning people up with lies about
the election but so when he said you
might hear that and say well that's
that's probably true no no no no what
what nancy said they
they can't do is make the trump riot
investigation about the steve scalise
shooting of what was it 2017
do people in chat know what year that
was i think it was 17.
they wanted to make the investigation
about the sixth
into the steve scalise shooting from
years ago
blm antifa protests from 2020
and their belief that the rioters were
justified in their anger
because the election was stolen
was it no i thought it was during trump
anyway
it it doesn't it doesn't matter what
you're okay let's listen to a few
it's just pathetic why would she make a
scope
that you couldn't get the answers to
they wanted answers to
things related to the steve scalise
shooting this could not be more
disingenuous right here
why would an officer's life not matter
to her
that's not what she said
that's why people objected people asked
for it before
she played six months with this why she
played her games and continued to do so
the senate acted two committees the
report is done
the fbi that senate that senate report
is just absolutely ridiculous okay
now last clip here uh asked about his
phone call with trump as the
insurrection was ongoing mccarthy
quickly changes the topic
yes listen to this and more specifically
you know many of this as politics them
think did jim jordan just say don't even
answer this is that what happened
you see jim jordan leans in and says
something right there
it's true it is politics by pelosi
what helps them is we will go forward
just as i promised them and we'll get
the answer to those questions
we'll make sure they're protected just
as we'll talk about officer evans too
who died on good friday
just we will go through and get the
answers
mr leader uh on may 20th in this room i
think you told us that you were prepared
to testify about your conversation with
president trump
on the afternoon of january 6. do you
still stand by that are you still
prepared to testify
my phone call is out there the question
is you make a phone call after people
are in the capital to advise the
president
of what's going on doesn't get to the
answer of
why were we ill prepared um well it sort
of does i mean
trump resisted sending in support it
sort it sort of goes right to the heart
of that
that's really playing politics and it
really shows that that's the issue that
they want to go to
if that's the issue they want to do then
they're going to do it okay lastly on
this
here is republican liz cheney um
who concedes the two people that pelosi
doesn't want on
the commission jim jordan and banks
are disgraceful actors there are three
members that the minority leader
proposed that the speaker did not object
to
right uh she is objected to two members
and the rhetoric
around this from the minority leader and
from those two members has been
disgraceful
this must be an investigation that is
focused on facts and
liz cheney republican says the behavior
of the two people pelosi is blocking
uh has indeed been disgraceful
here is uh liz cheney being asked again
about this
do you personally did you personally
urge the speaker to take this step
i agree with what the speaker has done
so she's in agreement there
and then one more clip and also mccarthy
of course
wants to become speaker next year do you
think that he deserves to be speaker
in the aftermath of his actions here uh
i think that any
uh person who would be third in line to
the presidency
must demonstrate a commitment to the
constitution and a commitment to the
rule of law
not exactly what kevin mccarthy has done
and uh minority leader mccarthy has not
done that
exactly right so very very nicely done
there big massive dumps
excellent job and they are just not
going to be allowed to have these people
okay
so that's the big news and it's
absolutely outrageous everything about
it is a gong show
gong show after gong show and tomorrow
on the podcast
um i'll have i'll have more coverage of
that okay before we move on to the next
thing
let me get to a few super chat but even
before that i want to say thank you to
some new twitch subscribers zack
prakowski
margo cabot k shreds jd foster rocks
as well as liquid ice numbers one
through five
also on my website huge thank you
to millie prescott milly prescott just
signed up at joinpakman.com
and his new member number six reminder
you can use the coupon code
indictment 21 to get a membership on my
website
all right a few super chats before i get
on to more frank says
mr packman you should expand mediavoice
by hiring
he has the income he should do it or
don't ask for money
you're saying i can't
what i can't mention membership unless i
hire more people that doesn't really
make sense
the money's for the people that
currently work for me why do i need to
hire more people that's weird
ryan says gnome chomsky has a talk where
he says unregulated capitalism and
representative democracy are
incompatible makes sense when you
consider regulatory capture and dark
money
do you believe this yeah unregulated
capitalism absolutely
absolutely sunil mahwani asks can you
explain how trump supporters can be
pro-operation warp speed
and anti-vaxx that seems inconsistent
sunil no
no no no listen guys trump did a great
job
handling the pandemic that wasn't
serious and was fake
for which we didn't need a vaccine which
trump heroically developed which his
supporters won't take
because it's a dangerous vaccine which
trump received
and felt fine after but which they
definitely aren't going to be getting
what's confusing about that that seems
completely consistent to me
maddie says david sir what is liz
cheney's long game does she see
something we don't or is she flying by
the seat of her pants
i don't attribute anything to her other
than she is a republican
not in the line of trump republicans
she's a horrible republican in a
different way
that that's all patrick says let's not
rehab liz cheney
exactly as i've said before i i disagree
with liz cheney about on just about
everything she voted with trump
almost completely she just on this issue
is being mildly reasonable that's all
it's not like you know let's let's not
go crazy and and go beyond that
um okay let's get to a few other things
here oh thanks to captain rickshaw
also for the for the prime membership i
appreciate that
let's briefly check back in on the
stephen kenneth destiny bonnell the
second sam cedar debate
let's put it that way i don't know if
it's 95 but we're not talking about the
that we're talking about we're not
talking about the cohort of people who
graduate college
we're talking about the cohort sam who
who who takes student loans
they're still on student loans that
includes people who don't graduate
and people who who who've graduated
uh but may be positioned in society in a
way that people who didn't have to take
student loan debt and get a college
degree are not
because 100 percent of your income can
be deployed
to you know after you're after your your
basic system oh the entire debate is
about student loans
okay all right all right got it got it
all right we'll check back in on that
let's go to a couple other things
finally we have found the moment from my
joe rogan appearance
where i pretended not to know that
stephen crowder is a comedian okay let's
listen
he specifically asked about that and
then they responded that's all you have
to do
wow that's what i'm using that's pretty
pretty straightforward it's pretty
straightforward
yeah this shirt's stupid but you know
he's a comedian
i mean that's what crowder's doing in
his doing the thing about mesa he's
mocking him for his appearance but
carlos meza specifically encouraged
people to throw
milkshakes at people that disagree with
him
and to harass them publicly and
humiliate them
so one thing doesn't justify the other
no it doesn't have that but that is
more egregious how asking people to
assault people
and asking people to physically
humiliate people in person
in my opinion is more egregious i don't
agree with
mocking his physical appeal well his
physical appearances
that's just what it is you know but
the sexual orientation aspect of it it's
like yeah i get it i get it's not it's
not nice
how far do you think so sorry this is
just a comedian thing goes
because i hear that a lot in just
excusing things that are said well he's
trying to do comedy
right so he's trying to make fun is he
yeah hold on but make
comedy and making fun of someone are two
different things like i don't do comedy
but i will sometimes make fun of things
people say
right but he's doing it to be funny he's
making fun of things specifically to be
funny and sometimes
you know when you do that you go too far
you cross lines i genuinely did not
realize that crowder does a comedy show
oh yeah
yeah so when he so his show is a comedy
show wow
yeah a lot of it is funny he does some
funny [ __ ] he really does
whether you agree with him or disagree
with him he's done some hilarious bits
i genuine i'm i'm reacting in real time
because i had no idea he has this bit he
does about this french socialist he puts
on a wig and pretends to be this
different
person he's pretending to be a
transgender person he's pretended to
he's done a bunch of these infiltration
videos where he'll go into these
ridiculous organizations and
ask them questions but it's very much a
comedy show
it's uh there it is guys all right so we
sounds hilarious i don't know how
anybody could not uh
how anybody wouldn't want to watch that
oh no sam cedar
all right so we got
we got that out of the way um i want to
say thanks to david miller who just
signed up on my website with the coupon
code
indictment 21 and is today's first new
member to use that
also want to say thank you to sav merc
and jen here for the twitch
subscriptions numbers
nine nine and ten there a lot of comedy
happening as you guys can tell
let me adjudicate one unban request when
people get banned on twitch they can
request to be unbanned
here is a user named postman but with a
lot of really edgy
exes and various different things
they came in and they said trump 2021
trump 2022 trump 2023
trump 2022 trump 2023
they then said david pakman is a libtard
they were banned and then their unbanned
request is
autocorrect that is a
permanent ban and they have been
permanently banned
easy it's too easy guys it's you're
making it way way way too easy
um okay good all right so we got that
done let's continue i have so much stuff
to catch up on
this is pretty funny okay so there were
some
moments there were some elements from
one of my recent streams
where i was commenting on steven destiny
bennell the second
commenting on hassan [ __ ] commenting on
the the word gusano
and someone did an edit where they made
it look
like my reaction to hassan was the
reaction actually to a mentally ill
voicemail caller so i'm gonna
i'm gonna play it because it's sort of
funny but it's mental illness isn't
funny but the edit is funny
but this is not actually my reaction
okay let's listen
that same caller called back uh
uh people uh want to make it uh out to
be a
want to make it out to be a [ __ ] like
slur or something it just means worm
okay
it's a it's a term that uh leftist south
americans
use okay so that's that's pretty serious
mental illness unfortunately that is sad
and and really
i mean listen in all seriousness we have
a problem in this country
not only of untreated forget about
untreated
undiagnosed even mental okay so
nicely done it's an edit i didn't really
say that okay
i was seriously reacting to a caller
that seemed very very much
um off the rails okay so that's just a
joke guys it's not an attack on hassan
or anything like that
i do want to say thank you to david
chadman who has just re-upped
their twitch prime subscription for 21
months in a row
as we continue here is a shapiro versus
pacman meme
that was sent to me strongest ben
shapiro fan
versus the weakest david pakman enjoyer
this is a pretty aggressive shot across
the bow i do want to warn people about
that
but this was sent to me and uh
okay that's that
i don't know that there's too much to
make of it it's just it's just a mimetic
element
that's all it is let me look at a couple
of other
um super chats here
cepha cepha hide i think i have that
here under classics
cephei cepha hyde exactly
all right the south has to be properly
held accountable for this spike in covid
start calling it the confederacy variant
or the lost
cause variant very much so
what's your opinion of nancy pelosi as a
politician how liberal or conservative
is she is he as shrewd as people say she
is
so here's the deal nancy pelosi is far
far
far to my right she has
uh tons of disastrous political
instincts
and represents some of the worst of the
establishment and yet at the same time
she is shrewd to some degree and
sometimes
understands the reality of a political
situation better than some of the
idealistic
people even in my audience sometimes do
i think i think that's basically as far
as i'll
uh as far as i'll go with that
okay here's something else that people
sent me matt gates and marjorie taylor
green over the weekend
did a rally in california basically
every venue
told them like no you can't come here so
they ended up doing it on the beach
and this guy trolled them really really
well i love this video take a look at
this
incredible one of the worst performances
of my career and they never doubted it
for a second
oh my god i'm so excited i'm so excited
i mean this all right everyone thinks
you're crazy i don't think you're crazy
people think you're a pedophile i don't
think you're a pedophile at all
i don't think he's a pedophile at all
times against him are totally false
[Laughter]
oh man isn't that the best the word
pedophile
was clearly the trigger there um i have
no idea who that guy is walter masterson
okay
yeah i'm not familiar with them really
really good
really really good all right let's watch
it one more time
incredible one of the worst performances
of my career and they never doubted it
for a second so the the audio here is
from ferris bueller's day off for people
who don't know
by the way it looks like farron cousins
posted this it looks like matt gates is
wearing the uniform
from where in save by the bell
they went and worked at the uh the beach
club
hold on yeah here oh man
isn't that just the best um that it
looks like that's what uh
big big uh big boomer energy yeah that's
that's essentially the outfit gates is
wearing okay
oh my god i'm so excited i'm so excited
i mean just all right everyone thinks
you're crazy i don't think you're crazy
people think you're a pedophile i don't
think you're a pedophile at all
i don't think he's a pedophile at all
times against him look at green by the
way she just continues the thumb up the
entire time
totally false they're totally false
thank you oh my god
okay um all right so that's that that
was really really nicely done i like
that one
um
yeah that's walter masterson apparently
i don't know who that is
walter masterson
um
comedian okay see guys that's a comedian
you know when joe rogan said to me
my this reaction that i had right right
here and he's pretended to
he's done a bunch of these infiltration
videos where he'll go into these
ridiculous organizations and
whether you agree with him or disagree
with him he's done some hilarious bits
i genuine i'm i'm reacting in real time
because i had no idea he has this bit he
does about this french socialist he puts
on a wig
that's not funny that's not funny this
actually
not that this that this guy seems to
actually be a comedian
oh no sam cedar all right next thing up
on the agenda
uh man
i don't even know how to bring this up
but i
i am going to have to uh fire a shot
across the bow
at the streamer known as vaush or vaash
and i'm kind of going back and forth
about
whether i should even do this but
vaush stole something from me okay
if i am known for anything
among the zoomer community
it's that i came up with the term giga
cringe
okay just check the receipts my friends
all right
look at what vaush tweeted to pim
tim poole today okay
not giving me any credit tim poole was
tweeting
anti-vaxx apologia and
vaush tweeted this is gigacringe dude
vaush has appropriated my term
guys we are maybe gonna have to go to
war with vaash
over this he just he didn't even like
there should be
an asterisk there or as some people call
it an
ass trick i've never understood
pronouncing it that way
there should really be a little
something there because that
i don't know or you know what we need to
hold up right now please go to urban
dictionary and
credit me for gigacringe we need to get
this in we need to a set we need to
establish it right there we actually
have some urban dictionary
um citations let me see here if i search
for my name
um
hold on what were the terms
feverant i believe is ours yep okay so
we have this one
please get it in get yeah i'm not really
going to war with vaush but we should
actually
get giga cringe in urban dictionary
feverant look at this
a portmanteau of feverish and fervent
unintentionally coined by lewis motomety
of the david pakman show
and this is a quote from the show from
2014. it seems like the only people who
are going to vote for rand paul are that
small libertarian section of the
republican party
and they're very passionate and feverant
and they support him with every fiber of
their being so that's a beautiful one
i'm trying to think what other ones we
have i think hatred mail
or just hatred here it is
hatred a person who zealously supports
his political
dogma to the point of bigotry towards
people of opposing opinions
a caller to the david pakman show who
records hatred male comments
expressing his or her ultra-conservative
views yeah very good so we're there
i think that we have a couple other but
we need to get
giga cringe in there it's not there oh
terra cringe that's interesting
a unit of cringe which is a thousand
giga cringes
oh boy i don't know that i like that
please we've got to get it in there
before this is all canceled okay
giga cringe we've got to define it
i'm not going to do it it should really
be something somebody else okay it
should really be somebody else
all right good let me get away from all
this stuff because i know that not
everybody in the audience nancy pelosi
on wednesday rejected two other not
everybody in the audience is relating to
this content okay so we got that
urban dictionary we're done with uh okay
let's let me check back in on the uh
steven debate yeah
what
is sam gone are they having a reading
period
the debate's over already sorry hold on
i got like 30. here have your
please just let me know that [ __ ] asleep
at the airport last night and still
think she's not going to make it home in
time
okay i guess it's over
well all right well let's just quickly
check in on hassan to see what's going
on there
in this case okay so one of my early
reasonings okay
or early on before i even start any of
this and i hear what you said
uh my early reasoning isn't um not like
uh not like a
like a coping like oh yeah it's gonna
it's gonna oh i feel better doing it
how do you do if people people are
always asking is this hassan watching
ethan watching
xqc then so wait is this xqc or is this
uh
um who is this
that was on sponsor just just willingly
is that um
there were so many barriers to get there
um
now like yeah even i as a 25 year old
i'm not like a zoomer right i i signed
up at
all the verifs all over i i have a
paypal with money i have a credit card
money i i have it all set up
anyone's ever made money you're too
[ __ ] stupid
all right i can't do this you know what
i'm noticing though hassan follows a
channel called
id oh that's that's me oh my god i was
just like that's that's just
i i'm such an idiot that's my channel
uh i was like id pacman that's really
weird but i understand it's just cut off
please do not clip that and never ever
ever
refer to that uh moment of the stream
ever again
um okay geez that was really humiliating
let's just get let's get off of that all
together i i that that was bizarre
okay let me get to yeah let's let's just
move on let me get to some voicemails i
didn't even get i was gonna look up who
who is id pacman that seems interesting
all right
let me get to some voicemails yeah i
have a whole bunch of them we're all the
way up to we we have only 110
unlisted two voicemails left at this
point
hey david um i've been in a complicated
situation
like these republicans they've been
talking about how people
have been on unemployment and
you know being too lazy to work you
mentioned that earlier
yeah but i've been in this loophole for
about a year
where i've been on medicaid because i
have expensive
medical bills but the thing is if i get
any job i lose all my health insurance
so it's cheaper for me not to have a job
it's ridiculous
i don't know what to do i don't know who
to work for that
that's a broken that will cover my needs
it's it's insane the pause button won't
work oh my god
that is a broken system that is a broken
system that's for sure
hey david um i've been in a complicated
situation
like these republicans they've been
talking about how people
have been on unemployment okay this is
the re-record of the exact same
voicemail so we're going to skip
sometimes people just call back and
leave the same voicemail again um
i don't know hey david um
i've been in a complicated situation
okay he's leaving the voicemail a third
time
let's continue hey david
um i've been in a complicated situation
like okay wait a second something
something weird is going on here
hold on a second um
that is something very very strange is
happening here
i almost feel like that's a glitch
yeah let's um
that might be a software issue like i'm
just rebooting my entire system
that can't possibly be the same guy uh
okay i i apologize i'm getting back to
uh
we're almost there
okay here we go let's let's get into
some other ones
so i was just reading up about um
chinese and
african relationships and for some
reason it was like trying to use the
chinese dragon
in the article to like okay
so is this reading up about um chinese
and
african relationships it's looping the
say all right something's wrong
the system has fallen guys the system
has totally fallen
uh okay let's see if we can check in
with stephen kenneth destiny bonnell ii
about his his uh debate with sam
cedar uh hey want to check in about the
sam cedar debate quickly let's see what
he says
um it look oh look somebody's
a delightful person on discord has been
calling me
uh all day that's interesting all right
let's talk to steven real
just real real quick here um
and see what's going on here oh hey
what's up buddy
steven how you doing how did um
how did the debate with sam go um i
thought it went
okay we kind of got weeded down on
something that i didn't think we'd get
weeded down on but
because i was remembering when you
debated my former um
economics professor richard wolff there
was a lot of time spent
talking about what isn't socialism what
isn't
feudalism what isn't a dictatorship what
isn't communism what it right way higher
regard than
a [ __ ] wolf yeah i don't know the
wolf guy is whatever i think sam's
pretty smart though i have a lot of
respect for him were you able to define
terms in a way that the conversation was
substantive
um yeah you were
i think so did anybody convince anybody
um no i think like i said we got lost in
the weeds on one topic so
yeah do you i've been thinking of going
back
to the debate game do do you think the
debates
need to be three hours long to be uh
good relevant content for the twitch
platform
what do you i that's a really loaded
question are you talking about like what
gets the most viewership what's the most
entertaining or what's like the best for
like getting a good conversation i would
say any of the above
because my experience is that when the
conversation goes longer than 45 minutes
a sort of fatigue starts to set in and
and
it doesn't i don't know how productive
it is
uh well i mean i it super depends on um
it's it's super depends on on what your
goal is those
all of those things require vastly
different types of things yeah
like if you um if you want something the
most entertaining stuff is when you're
screaming at each other and calling each
other names okay
and like going real hard but that's
obviously not a good way to get
like a good conversation high quality
conversation where you know points are
being spelled out correctly and
everything right
right so you would not advise me to do
like a three hour like shout fest for
example
i love those if you can find somebody
who wants to do it that's some funny
[ __ ] in my opinion oh see i assume i
assume that's what everybody wants
you're saying it's actually tough to
find people who want to do that
well the problem is that most people
don't have the
mental constitution to endure in those
environments for very long i see so
those
those communities full of people that do
that self-destruct very quickly
um yeah who do you think on the left
right now
and by the left i mean people who are
sort of like aligned
more or less with you politically who do
you think is doing the best job of like
smacking down the right wingers right
now
uh well i mean you ask me this is a
space that i'm in so i'm going to give
you a biased answer obviously i mean i
would say i do
no well of course other than you other
than you other than me
so there's like this weird trend that
happened where if it feels like people
on the left for a while didn't want to
engage with people on the right and then
i think i came along and i started
debating a lot and then like vosh and
other people came along in a song they
wanted to be like debaters and then they
started to engage with the write more
but now it feels like we've kind of gone
back to the not engaging with the right
and now it's just all left-leaning
people fighting with themselves
so like when i look at a lot of the
discourse today from like um the
brianna gray or jimmy dore or the young
turks
or like a lot of it like and i'm not
trying to blame any of these individual
parties but it seems like most of the
fighting right now happens between like
is aoc like a sellout gusano [ __ ] or is
biden like a traitor to the working port
right
like that seems to be all the
conversations it seems like we don't
really talk too
or much about any republican
right-leaning people anymore
i have to yeah like what i say yeah i
have like two views on that on the one
hand
i do think that dialogue is good when
there can be
sort of like points of agreement found
at the same time
uh you know new poll 55 of trump voters
believe that the january sixth riots
were an act of defending freedom so it's
like is there really common ground to
find with those people it's kind of
it's gotta be yeah that's my problem is
it like i think that's why that
conversation is more important than like
you know like is our ideal society
socialist or communist like rather than
going like so far left into [ __ ]
crazy land
where it's like 15 an hour isn't enough
i want 35 and i'm like okay i don't give
a [ __ ] about you
because half the goddamn republican
party like believes in
jewish space lasers right i think that
that is like way way way way way more
important
um and that's right like i've started
like blocking and getting away from like
95
of these insane people on the left
because like i don't know anybody in my
real life personal life
that wants us to [ __ ] have like you
know mao come back from the from the
dead and like roll tanks through the
united states and makes the communist
revolution but my own mom is an
anti-vaxxer my own
won't get a vaccine even though we've
had two family members die from the
coronavirus you know
wow um so like those conversations are
so much more important to me
i think they're more important to this
country than like you know did jimmy
dore
sexually harass uh you know some girl uh
the girl from the young turks i don't
mean to anna caspering right right she's
not just some girl inside i mean to
sound rude
but like like or or like the is you know
is biden left leaning enough like
why aren't they coming through and
claiming control of the senate the past
medicare for like i don't i don't
want those conversations right now like
i genuinely want to talk to people that
are trying to tell me why they don't
think that vaccines work
um because we're like we're on the verge
of a second nationwide lockdown we're on
the verge of like a second worldwide
epidemic
we're not already experiencing it with
the with the delta variant you know
so you mean that there's there's let me
see if i can interpret because you're
shot out of a cannon today stephen
you're saying you're saying that there's
lower hanging fruit that would make much
of a
bigger difference whereas like the
debate between
if we got to social democracy would we
want to keep going to socialism is less
immediately relevant than just like hey
guys can you go and get vaccinated
yes wow yes that is exactly what i mean
or like rather than arguing like over
whether medicare for all or a public
option is the best like
let's talk about let's make sure that we
all actually believe that our election
happened and it was real
okay yeah because what is the percent
it's like 40 of americans don't or
not americans trump how many republicans
believe that the election was stolen i
think about um
i think something like 60 of trump
voters think it was stolen
yeah like it's insane that's
unbelievable to me
yeah um wow
yeah wow and nobody on the left is
having those conversations anymore
right now we're all just talking about
like what perfect like how are we gonna
work on the commune like am i gonna be
doing art nine hours a day or eight
hours a day
when i work on the factory farm for a
little bit to make sure we all have
avocados to eat like that's what it
feels like most of the conversations on
the left are now i just
i'm not there for it i don't give a [ __ ]
we're speaking of which by the way where
are you on
the grafting of avocado trees
grafting of avocado trees yeah i don't
know what that means
you've not taken a position on that what
is the grafting of avocado trees
well the thing is a lot of avocados if
you just plant the seed you know that
big
the pit you'll get a tree and you'll
wait 10-12 years and then there will be
no fruit
and so the new the new hot thing to
quote donald trump
is that you start a new avocado tree but
then you graft onto it
a little branchling from a known
fruiting avocado tree to
to ensure you don't spend 12 years
waiting for nothing
oh is that a real thing or that's
absolutely real
oh okay are you in favor of that i guess
is the question
is there a reason not to be not that i'm
aware of well then i guess it sounds
fine
yeah i i'm with you i'm with you okay
um all right good and then from the
standpoint
of um future debates you got anything
else planned
i have a debate against some
conservative lady soon lisa elizabeth i
don't know who the [ __ ] this is about
whether or not there is like systemic
racism in policing
which i think is pretty easy um i am on
a i'm on a panel tomorrow
for all white people wait what do you
hold on a second you're representing the
white race on the panel
it's all it's whites only on the panel
and it's gonna be a conversation about
white spaces and if they're needed so
that'll be a very interesting
conversation
wow who else is on that um a bunch of
smaller political
creators but man i can't wait for the
twitter headlines on that one
is it like is it a white supremacy panel
you know i'm sure everybody'll think
it'll be maybe it will be who knows
we'll find out i guess when we start
chatting do you know who's organizing it
um yes
are you willing to say uh
it's a guy that does political panels on
twitch called prime case but this is all
like kind of like smaller creators so
this is not in person right what's wrong
with it being in person no i'm asking if
it is i just i'm just saying i i'm what
you have that like downturn on your
voice oh no no no i'm just i'm assuming
that this will be you're not like
driving somewhere for this
yeah it's online wow that's that's a
that's crazy
and the point will be to determine if
anything like white student union white
spaces are needed
yeah i guess okay wow and what will your
position be
um i'm not actually sure anymore i don't
know
there might need there maybe you need a
space for white people to decompress we
get a lot of hate online these days
david and all feelings are valid right
the only concern i have is that as a
cuban american
are you even are you valid for that's
the problem with this identity stuff i
don't even know
i have a multi-racial experience so i
can inhabit multiple spaces
thank you very much okay okay
uh say i i have a very white experience
in the united states
i think you're socially assigned race
would be white i agree with that
well i'm glad we agree i wouldn't be
allowed on that panel right like i'm
i'm definitely not like because i'm
fully argentinian
well i'm looking at you right now can
you open your eyes real wide for me let
me see him
i think he'd be okay i'd be okay on the
panel or off the panel
i think he'd be okay on the panel oh
okay all right well well maybe i'll
maybe i'll look into doing that
uh i'm i don't know i'm worried about
the branding of you
participating in this i know that's
gonna be the funnest part
known written house defender blm hater
destiny on all white
exclusive panel that's i'm just waiting
for the or the headlines on that one
uh well i mean good luck with that
that's that i'm i'm a little worried i
wish we would have run this by your
agent i don't know
oh i've gone through four of those for
some reason they seem to keep quitting
is it because they keep telling you
listen if you do the white only panel i
can't really represent you
um no usually because they open my
twitter one time and then they just
ghost me
hold on i thought you were banned from
twitter um
i i am my past twitters i mean yeah my
friend has a twitter account and we
share
some views sometimes so they're worried
that there might be a lot of crossover
between my personal views and my friends
views so
gotcha okay hey is it is it true that
the host of the panel
is not white tomorrow yeah i have a big
conversation with him about that i don't
know if we're gonna have him maybe
log out of the conversation for an hour
and then check back in on us
we're probably gonna need like an
official person to answer the zoom door
or something to make sure he's not
intruding on our white space but
um maybe he's got a white friend i don't
know we'll figure it out i guess what
i'm asking is
is the host interested in the topic by
virtue of not being white
himself uh i think it's just interest i
think
oh i don't want to miss quote but i
think it came up as a joke where because
he has a plan
because he is uh he is black and he has
a panel called all black everything
and so they have like and i think
somebody is a joke i think in one of
these shows like we should have an
all-white panel call it all white
everything and i think they kind of he
ran with the joker's like yeah [ __ ] it
let's do it one time
and we'll see what happens or whatever
so i don't think he's planning on just
being like a normal a normal thing
i think it's just like a all right well
it sounds pretty compelling
hey let me just run one other thing by
you um
as i'm sure you know i coined the term
gigacringe uh close to a year ago
and today a user uh who streams under
the handle
vosh responded to tim poole
using that term and didn't credit me do
you think he should have credited me
um i mean if he didn't credit you i
would fully
support you uh mobilizing some lawyers
um open with a cease and desist tell him
you want retroactive credit and then if
he doesn't you should just
you should just unleash the full force
of david pakman's show onto that
production
i would say what do you think the
damages would be
to hammer to you like that i could that
i could sue for
um well giga cringe i would probably do
i would probably do a lot of searching
around probably try to value each
impression that you found on twitter
on google um i try to see how much money
he made off of it
yeah that like if he used gigacringe in
a show i'd say probably five to ten
percent of the ad revenue earnings on
that show are probably rightfully yours
wow people sticking around yeah because
you know how it is with these things
like
getting a license up front is always
cheaper than having to then
fix it later you know yeah for sure so
i mean what would you license gigacringe
for i would probably
mechanical license like what kind of
like yeah you'd
probably just a trolling license
gotcha yeah okay i don't know anyway
we'll we'll look into it but in any in
all seriousness
vosh was involved in a pretty cringy
thread not on his behalf but
tim poole was like he seems to not
understand vaccines it was really weird
i don't know if you saw it
i every time people don't understand
things
they end up like when you talk them
through it they end up remaking the
thing
i don't know if you know that like so
like for libertarians you'll be like how
do you figure out like who
has land and they're like well you know
you'd have an agreement between two
people what if there are three or four
people involved well you'd probably get
one person that would be kind of like
arbitrating
okay like they reinvent government right
and i noticed like i argued with a guy
about vaccine related stuff before and
he's like i don't believe in vaccines i
believe in an immune system
and i was like what do you mean by that
and he's like well i think that if i
have exposure to the virus over time and
it's like
okay yeah like imagine if we could come
up with something
that would get your immune system to
where you want it to be
like it would yes exactly that's what
i'm looking at like yeah he ends up like
basically reinventing vaccines
on twitter and i'm like yeah like i
agree i'm not even disagreeing
everything you're saying is totally
right you're just
you're so close you know yeah i was
thinking like uh
maybe a way to get some of these right
wingers to get vaccinated
would be to spread as a rumor that
liberals are trying
to keep the vaccine from them yeah
maybe i mean really it's as good an idea
as any i think
yeah probably something that's really
sad is like
there is a future where donald trump
getting elected would have been better
for the entire world
uh because it might be the case that
republicans would have actually gotten
vaccinated if trump was president
instead of biden
that's really sad to me yeah because the
other countries are like clamoring for
vaccines and the u.s
has infinite of them and they just don't
take that i know no i don't i think
you're probably right
on that it would have been obviously
better not to have trump
at the at the beginning of the whole
thing but i think you're right because
the liberals were going to get
vaccinated either way
but you i i think it's hard to argue
that you're wrong about that
it's really really really frustrating to
me but are you gonna get another are you
are you
sorry it's really frustrating when
people talk to me about like
hypothetically in the future there might
be side effects that we don't know about
that we haven't seen anywhere that might
affect
it's like okay yeah maybe but why don't
you compare that to what you know
right now about the coronavirus why
don't you go like
like i don't understand how you think
that this trade is intelligent and then
all these people end up getting infected
anyway and it's like oh
sorry go ahead yeah no i was going to
say that um
it uh well first i was going to ask you
if you're looking to get any additional
doses
um i'm unfortunately i've hit a soft cap
on how many i can get
because most of the healthcare workers
now at the places that i've been vaccing
up at recognize me um so they usually
call security and i have to leave
i thought about going out of city but i
don't know how i feel traveling yet
for them um so we'll see in the future
yeah wow
okay well that's that's super aggressive
and then the last thing i wanted to ask
you about was
um are you worried about
the um you know the marjorie taylor
greens the
matt gates that type of thing if they do
get reelected in 22
it's just gonna reinvigorate all of
these aggressive trumpists and then it
could be i mean i
it could be a decade after that before
we we excise them
here is um okay i think i've given too
many takes for your audience to warm up
to me so let me give you a hot take to
make them all hate me again please
i think that um people looking
at marjorie green taylor um trying to
like get her stripped of like committees
or whatever in congress and all that
[ __ ] yeah i disagree with that
wholeheartedly i think that she should
be allowed to participate in government
in any way that she wants to if she's an
elected official
i think that sometimes i think that
people on the left right now are too
fixated on trying to get the processes
rigged in their favor
rather than like trying to change the
minds of the american people and i think
that the best way to get more people on
your side is with
as biden said kitchen table issues so
getting like this big infrastructure
bill
like trying to win over like more
american minds through like dedicated
stimulus to working-class americans
i think that going in that direction and
winning elections that way i think is
way better than this demonization of
people
because like like it or not having a
common enemy
uh like is it or having people attack
you is just a really big way to rile up
support for your side
so like who cares about marjory
greenfield she's [ __ ] crazy
you know if you know she's crazy you
know she's crazy if you don't know she's
crazy then somebody in the left shirt is
[ __ ] isn't going to convince you
otherwise right
it shouldn't be whether or not marjorie
green taylor is insane and into q anon
it should be whether or not she voted
for the infrastructure bill or whether
or not she voted for stimulus or whether
or not she voted for
uh the coronavirus relief or whether or
not she wants to keep your child tax
credit around i think if democrats can
just keep
centered on these economic issues and
make it about that they're not the party
that wins the culture work they're the
party that makes your life better
materially i think that that's like a
way better path forward
yeah but what so i agree about going
back to policy a lot of these people
don't have
any policy but i think what you're
missing is if you ignore
everything other than policy they just
keep suppressing the vote so you've got
to keep working on that that's not a
cultural issue i'm not saying
fight about trans girls and sports i'm
not saying that but
you can't just do economic issues
because then they pass 250 voter
suppression bills and it doesn't matter
that people like your economic policy
uh maybe that's another conversation but
well it's part of this one
yeah there's we if you ever really want
to get into the wii i don't think voter
suppression is anywhere near as big a
deal in the us as people make it out to
be i think that the big issue is
interest around elections
um and i think you can look at
disparities between local elections and
national elections or you can look at
the disparities between like how did
people vote when there was more voter
suppression for obama
versus how did they vote for you know
trump provided like i think that whether
or not people want to vote is way more
influenced by their uh interest in an
election
rather than the amount of voter
suppression that exists yeah well
but there's a lot of articles that are
written about that no well i mean i
think here here's where i would agree
with you
which is because of the low voter
participation rate
it is undeniable that if either side in
a national election
could just boost turnout five percent it
dramatically out does the level of voter
suppression that's currently going on
that's i think that that's a
mathematical reality
of course yeah neither party ever does
that really i mean you know what i mean
is this past election there was just
record turnout
on both sides because there was more
interest but the i i i think what you're
saying is mathematically sound
but not a reason to ignore it yeah yeah
for sure trump brings it up a lot and
people make fun of him for it but trump
got the second most votes of any
president in u.s history true
you need to people need to remember that
people need to stop assuming that the
whole country is progressive and we just
need to figure out how to pass the laws
there's a whole bunch of people in this
country that disagree politically with
each other and we need to do a better
job at bridging these gaps because if it
doesn't happen this country is
completely [ __ ]
now i do have to ask about what some in
my audience feel
is maybe a a hypocritical or uh
concerning statement that you made um
one of my viewers points out that
you're insisting that the left should
really stick to debating relevant and
important topics
but then you're also on a panel about
white spaces and that there may be an
inconsistency there
oh um yeah that that might actually be
something that seems confusing uh let me
clear it up for that viewer
so my name is stephen bonnell my gamer
name is destiny and i stream politics on
twitch.tv i'm not an elected lawmaker
i see sits inside congress that actually
makes laws or determines what the
national agenda is going to be
legislatively so
when you met i see i see yeah you know
yeah i know people mix it up a lot but
um
believe it or not there's a lot of
things that i say and do um i personally
now this is just my personal description
i don't think that biden should spend
you know six hours a day hard stuck in
diamond four
but i like to do it um now that might
make me a hypocrite to some but to
others i would point out that i'm not
the sitting president of the united
states if jimmy carter wanted to play
league you know
maybe that would be okay or whatever but
yeah so when you met you met elected
officials that are on the left need to
focus on that not necessarily game
streamers
no or or pundits like like let me be
clear i'm sorry materialism are
important but social issues are
important too you know trans people and
lgbt issues like those are important
um i just think that democrats you you
only have so much like political capital
and political will to get things done
right that needs to be put in the
highest like what what is it it's kind
of like when you're a business owner
right like what is the least amount of
work i can do for the biggest payoff you
always knock out those issues first
you're not going to buy a 50 000 camera
if you don't have lights in your studio
right you're not going to buy a 200 000
internet connection if you don't have a
computer to start right that's
that's all i'm saying is like focus on
your important issues first and right
now i think the economic stimulus is
absolutely that issue well you've really
said it all
um from from a business standpoint i did
want to ask you
i'm looking to delve into the uh
i'm looking to do a streamer interview
series
are there big time streamers that have
interesting business models or who you
think would otherwise not be opposed
to engaging with people like me that do
primarily politics which many people
stay away from because it can be toxic
um literally everybody in the smaller
politics community on twitch would
probably love
an opportunity for an interview let me
clarify non-politics people
streamers that are not in politics yeah
streamers that aren't in politics that
would talk to you oh for what kind of
interviews
just interviews about their streaming
you know presence their online presence
etc
i mean i imagine almost anybody would
probably say yes no
wow wow like who are even the big
streamers i should be talking to
you should just straight up message
pokemon um
executive pokemon um yeah these people
will
they'll 100 go for it for sure wow
uh okay x so hold on was that
x q c yeah x q it's
well i'm kidding around i know who i'm
getting around about that yeah it's
actually x cube cow but yeah
xq cow that i will make a note of geez i
don't want a humiliating thing where i'm
like hey you know
okay um yeah i feel like the big egos
can be a factor on twitch
yeah a little bit but you know i mean
you're in the youtube world they're big
egos are here too for sure
yeah no so i guess so i guess so
all right well i think it's all going
really well are you
uh are you back are things going okay
with twitch for you or i'm not even sure
how to ask the question
yeah they're going okay right now i got
my subscriber button back so
if you've got amazon primes uh don't
stub the david sub to me instead so you
know yeah
i'll just be i'll be i'll just say make
sure you're using your bezos bucks don't
leave them in bezos's pocket i won't
i won't i'm not gonna patronize the
audience by saying what you're saying
but yeah okay
you don't want him to go to the to outer
space again right
one time i think one is probably enough
yeah i think
you know i think we probably learned all
we're going to learn from bezos going
one time
think so yeah we could go in the future
though would you do it would offered you
the chance yeah like five thousand ten
thousand dollars for a rocket trip up to
you could float around for like a minute
and then come back
yeah i've said i'm i'm not like super
eager to be in the first
10 people to do it but yeah i would be
interested i would certainly be
interested
okay cool any trips planned
um i got all sorts of trips planned i'm
probably going to canada
um london for a little bit and then
sweden and then amsterdam next month
so wow wow
can't yep they're finally opening up
again so i want to get out there before
the delta variant has turned everybody
into walking zombies you know
what's your what's do you have an
airline preference not that you're
sponsored by any airline but
um i like um
i like delta's planes american airline
is pretty good too
oh yeah those two i would say i like
planes that have outlets at every seat
so i can plug my laptop and play video
games that's important to me
oh you game you game the entire flight
absolutely because the
brain rot games that i play i can pass
like 10 hours in like 30 minutes it's
unbelievable the time
it's like a vortex you enter yeah
basically yeah okay and then
inside of europe what's your preference
i don't know european airlines suck i
don't know yeah i i think i do most of
my travel in europe was like not air
portugal okay jesus christ
i'm not racist but anything happening
with portugal is just [ __ ] horrible
do you mean
do you mean tap portugal whatever
has the name portugal on it or comes
from portugal is just a bad
thing their airport sucks their airline
sucks everything about that
country needs to be avoided oh my god i
think portugal is one of the most
interesting i've had such a great time
in portugal and i had a beautiful flight
on
on tap portugal's i think they have like
the a330 neo now
uh and i want to make very clear i
disagree with everything
kenny is saying here uh lisbon is
fantastic
sintra cascais porto ever it's all i
love it i absolutely love it
maybe outside of that main airport maybe
maybe it's better but who's like sarah i
mean listen
if you if you go to the old terminal at
charles de gaulle in paris
you probably would be like oh i don't
want to go to paris but that has nothing
to do with paris
yeah i've been through i think a cdg a
few times you have to like bust around
outside sometimes to get to different
parts of the airport it's interesting
oh stephen we got to get you vip so you
don't have to do that i can't imagine
that a cuban-american streamer as
prominent as you isn't being brought
around in a different way
i've always i'm like in some ways
i i really don't spend my money on much
do you do you ride like first class
business class i'm always like back in
economy i'm in the
i'm on the very end of that plane on the
lap where the seat can't go back anymore
because it's against the [ __ ] wall
yeah that's where i ride at you want the
the seat that doesn't recline well
listen often
when in the days of being hired to speak
places
usually they would fly me business class
or whatever yeah but honestly at this
point i have so many
miles and points and all this stuff that
that there's there's frequent upgrades
to be had yeah
i don't know if it's a poor person thing
growing up or if it's a rpg video game
thing around i have so many points too
but i'm always scared of spending them i
like oh no no no you got to get over
what are you saving the points for what
are you what are what are you saving
them for
i don't know i'm just what if i run out
exactly but you've never even needed
them this is the conundrum no
that's why they okay i'll start doing
first class flights but if i run out of
points
if i run out of points davey i'm gonna
be really upset with you okay i'm gonna
be invoicing you for my flights
okay yeah well all right talk talk to my
agent about that i don't know
um okay well steven listen i uh i wish
you the best uh hello to the dgg
community and and everybody there um
uh molina of course molina destiny
bonnell ii
and just everybody at the steven
headquarters
thanks i'll make sure that they all know
that they've got a message from you and
uh they all say hi
back as well of course by the way i
popped into one of molina's streams
recently and
nobody knew what was going on i think a
lot of the people who who are following
her may not be in my audience
um yeah the crossover is probably not
that high
but i think that's because she's more of
like an international focus being
swedish rather than us
who are you know strictly american i
think that's exactly what it is i think
that's exactly what it is
yeah yeah sure yeah uh all right stephen
be well thank you for the call
i called you but i still thank you for
the call thank you for checking it i
appreciate it okay all right we'll talk
to you soon
bye bye all right there he goes uh
stephen kenneth
destiny bennell ii he really has
said it all and um
yeah i mean i think the frequent flyer
miles thing is a lot hold on let's
listen to what he's saying real quick
timestamp of the h3h debate start
okay um channel points and frequent
flyer miles
i feel like are similar in some sense
uh people are just saving they're
hoarding they're hoarding all their
twitch channel points and then it's like
well
at some point you got to use these
things you know they don't they don't
have unlimited value there's only a few
things you can sort of do with them
um all right very good thanks everybody
we'll have more on the pelosi stuff
tomorrow
and um that's really that's really it
for today
oh by the way is the trump rally
happening saturday and if so can anyone
find out and email me what time it's
happening because if it is i plan to
stream it
um but if it's not then there won't be
anything to stream all right so please
let me know send me an email
i want to know what's happening